[Laughter]
Hyundai Tucson Chevy Silverado Kia
Explorer.
Ford Explorer. Let's get it. Very loose.
The good thing about a good quality
battery maintainer is you can save
problems like this.
See how this post is super wiggly
and sparking? With a good battery
maintainer, you technically don't even
need a battery for the key programming
process. So, get a good one. If you need
to boost the vehicle, that's a different
story, but also get a good one.
Okay. 2018 Ford Explorer using the Auto
Propad G2
mobilization. Agree to the terms. Ford,
no key detected. We're going to fix
that.
Okay. So, this one we're going to go by
vehicle because we if we can turn the
ignition on, automatic search will work
where it'll just pick up the correct
immobilizer system. If you can't and
it's all keys lost, then we just got to
go by vehicle. This is a smart key. We
are working on an Explorer.
This is a 2018.
Turn on the ignition switch. If you lose
all the keys, please turn the hazards
on. So, we're going to turn on the
hazard light right here.
Click okay to continue.
So, we'll get a B-roll shot of where I'm
going to put the key, but it belongs in
the center console in here for the key
learning procedure. So, just slide the
key in there. We'll wait for this to
think. Um, okay. So, we're going to
click on all keys lost.
The alarm is not active. We open up the
door. The alarm isn't sounding. So,
that's less work for us. Alarm not
active. It's going to delete all the
keys. And it requires at least two new
keys to be able to start the engine. So
I click yes. Turn on the hazard lights,
which they already are. Press okay.
Press okay.
We got some things clicking and some
things turning on here. That's a good
sign.
This car is acting a bit unusual.
Anyway, successfully erased the keys.
That's good. Place the key in the
programming slot. Press okay.
Door lock cycle. That means it's
successfully programmed. On the dash
here, it says not enough keys learned.
If you can see that on the tool, it says
the key programming was successful.
There's one key. Okay. We do want to
program another one. So, hit yes. We're
going to swap our keys out.
Press okay.
Listen for those door locks to cycle.
There we go. Key successfully programmed
on the dash.
All good things. Tool says key is
successfully programmed. The current
number of keys is two. We don't want to
program another one. That's all there is
to it. Let's see if this works.
Lock and unlock. Working. Lock and
unlock. Working.
And a very dead battery once again.
Let's grab a booster to make sure it
starts.
Good. Booster's hooked up.
Oh, no. No, no, no. There we go. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay,
both keys have successfully started it.
So, now we're going to move to our
cutting, picking, all that jazz. Thomas
has got the locks picked already. So,
now he's cutting the blades to see if
they turn in the door lock cylinder, and
then we'll be done.
So, right now, Thomas is cutting a test
blade to make sure that we don't waste a
really expensive key and get the cuts
incorrect. So, as soon as he's done
that, we'll test it and then we'll
actually finish cutting the keys.
[Music]